[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre cette
fuite loisirs à vis de vous retrouver
pour ce 20e numéro le sommaire de ce
jeudi 14 février rangez votre pot de
glace votre comédie romantique et votre
pyjama en pilou pilou
nous vous donnons cinq idées de sorties
pour une saint-valentin célibataire que
vous soyez bourreau des coeurs ou coeur
d'artichaut vous trouverez votre soirée
coup de coeur sans transition c'est
l'année du cochon de terre pour ce
dernier week-end des festivités du
nouvel an chinois l'association jardins
passions partage vous apprend les bases
de la cuisine asiatique
enfin nous recevrons dans cette édition
patrick foltête de lion's club de saint
germain en laye pour nous parler du 17e
salon du vin et de la gastronomie pas de
valentin ou de valentine pour la fête
des amoureux nous avons repéré pour vous
des idées de sorties à faire en solo on
vous invite à faire une rencontre avec
votre soirée idéale
bonsoir à tous la compagnie des tisseurs
de son jeu vous invite à une
saint-valentin plaine de jeux et de
mystère c'est diviser les enquêteurs
pour ne pas vous faire démasquer
chacun tient son rôle pour cette murder
party thématiques à l'espace decaux
villes de voisins-le-bretonneux le 17
février pour être plus spectateur la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux vous propose de passer la soirée
avec valentina del pearls l'effeuilleuse
burlesque promet un show plein de plumes
et paillettes saupoudré d'humour déjanté
si vous voulez entrer dans la danse et
développer votre sensualité pour de
nouvelles conquêtes penser à la bachata
cette danse originaire de république
dominicaine est considérée comme la plus
romantique des danses latines et
l'association mambo la danse de saint
germain en laye vous propose des stages
intensifs pour débutants une fois par
mois
le prochain aura lieu le 31 mars idéal
pour ses amours de printemps retrouver
l'amour pour soi la saint valentin est
l'occasion rêvée pour réaliser cette
introspection et réfléchir à ses
relations passées
évitez les schémas répétitifs de
dépendance affective car pour trouver un
amour st il faut d'abord s'aimer soi
même peut pas au sein de cette relation
un moment pour ouvrir son coeur pour
aller rechercher quels ont été les
expériences douloureuses les guérir
grâce à un travail en sophrologie avec
donc un travail sur l'inconscient qui va
permettre de libérer ses mémoires
enfin pour les fraîchement séparée qui
n'ont pas encore dépassé le stade de la
rancoeur
le centre de conservation pour animaux
hemsley au royaume uni vous propose de
baptiser un cafard avec le nom de votre
ex pour deux auront vous offrez ce
patronyme brice coeur allume de cette
très charmante petite bête et vous aider
aux différents projets du zoo
alors le coeur on y croit l'année
prochaine vous ne serez plus seul et
pour une soirée romantique aux
chandelles pensez à choisir de bons
produits
justement ce week-end c'est la 17e
édition du salon du vin et de la
gastronomie à saint-germain-en-laye avec
nous en plateau patrick rôle tête vous
êtes commissaire du salon
bonjour bonsoir alors 17e édition ce
salon c'est un vrai rendez vous dans un
lieu prestigieux tout offert 7 l'ancien
manager royal du 19e siècle qui est bien
sûr classé aux monuments historiques qui
est un bâtiment sublime mais qui est
près du château de saint germain et qui
fait que ce salon tous les ans reproduit
depuis 17 ans 17 ans pourquoi parce que
c'est très demandé cette reprise et et
les habitués qui reviennent d'une année
sur l'autre à 90%
nous avons toujours les mêmes exposants
nous avons que peu de changements ici on
s'écoutait on aurait quasiment le double
jusqu'à ce jour j'ai toujours des
demandes
voilà donc ces explosions alors ces
exposants beaucoup dans le domaine
viticole dans la gastronomie également
est également dans la culture bio
d'ailleurs sur le côté viticole
également dans les produits charcuterie
parce que vous savez que ça bouge
beaucoup dans ce domaine est aujourd'hui
nous avons de plus en plus de
présentation dans cet esprit ils
viennent de toutes les régions ils
viennent de toutes les régions de france
donc on a toutes les les accents de nos
charmants territoires qui sont là à
partir de de demain oui puisqu'ils
s'installent dès demain et samedi
dimanche et effectivement une grande
fête
vous accueillez du monde à chaque fois
c'est vraiment 17 ans a perdu 17 ans ça
perdure il ya une ambiance formidable
nous avons de plus en plus de
visiteurs d'abord parce que le bâtiment
et culturel en même temps très
intéressant quand on ne connaît pas et
puis c'est très convivial et les lions
sont là pour les recevoir et mener une
ambiance qu'on attend tous surtout
aujourd'hui justement les lions dans les
endroits les lions alors l'union ce sont
des hommes et des femmes
le créateur c'est un américain melvin
jones qui a créé cette institution en
1917 qui est un club de service où se
retrouvent des hommes et les femmes et
le jeudi la devise lyon c'est servir
donc le but est de faire des actions
pour je dirais rentrer de l'argent
redistribuer faut savoir que celle ong
la plus importante au monde parce que
beaucoup ne savent pas il ya des
exemples frappants sait que lyon salza y
meurt et partie du lion ce club de saint
germain en laye après on alzheimer mais
c'est au tout départ un dément qui est
toujours présent et qu'un médecin qui
est au sein de notre club nous avons le
combat pour l'autisme
nous participons à la je dirais nous
plantons des arbres au sénégal nous
créons des écoles nous avons le téléthon
le téléthon a été créé par le par le
lion's-club également c'est devenu
téléthon mais ou à l'origine c'est le
lion ce qu'ils faisaient et à saint
germain en laye nous sommes une
trentaine c'est un club qui va voir 62
ans au mois de juin cette année c'est
une ambiance super mais on travaille
beaucoup et tout ce qui est rentré comme
argent est reversé complètement pour les
heures il n'y a pas un centime
qu'ils soient pris par les membres du
club et donc on viendra vous découvrir
ce week end au salon du vin et de la
gastronomie merci avec un plaisir de
venir sur notre planète merci beaucoup
on continue de se donner faim mais dans
des saveurs à l'autre bout du monde
c'est l'année du cochon de terre le
nouvel an chinois a démarré le 5 février
avec le jour du coq
quinze jours de festivités autour de la
culture asiatique il atteint son point
d'orgue de ce week end pour l'occasion
en cpt2 faut de l'association jardon
jardin passion partage vous propose en
atelier pour apprendre à cuisiner bonne
m
et nous sauter directement chez elle une
douzaine de personnes pourront s'initier
à enrouler les pâtés impériaux
avec un peu de chance la météo sera
clémente et l'atelier pourra même se
dérouler dans son jardin bucolique
c'est au nouvel an vietnamien il ya
plein de produits vendus dans les
supermarchés et j'ai des gens qui me dit
ah bon vous les biens achetés on veut
bien acheté ma pensée pas quoi faire
alors j'ai des bombes dans ce cas nous
on va perdre un cours de cuisine
asiatique et en général dans la cuisine
asiatique les gens aiment bien faire des
mêmes
même ceux qui sont déjà venus surtout
celle là l'est sont surtout des femmes
qui sont déjà venus venaient elles
reviennent encore à chaque fois parce
qu'elles veulent refaire des mêmes et
pour les congés mais parce que là où
c'est ce qu'on met dedans et on sait
très bien ce qu'on peut congeler
pourront pas sortir un ou deux mois
après n'y a aucun problème et vous
pouvez vous inscrire à l'atelier en
contactant l'association par mail
enoteca verneuil-sur-seine l'école du
dragon bleu les commerçants et la ville
s'associent pour faire vivre ce nouvel
an chinois ce samedi 7 février pour une
deuxième édition de festivités la ville
de plaisir mais les cordes à l'honneur
une semaine de la guitare pour mettre en
valeur la venue d'un artiste phare de
l'instrument emmanuel rossfelder il a
donné une master class merkel mercredi
vous pourrez le voir sur scène le 15
février
retrouvez toute la programmation de
cette semaine rythmée sur le site
internet de la ville depuis 29 ans
l'association cinéma publique organise
le festival international de cinéma
jeune public ciné junior
l'événement se déroule principalement
dans le val de marne mais aussi dans
d'autres villes d'île de france et
notamment à magny les hameaux
le jeune public pourra découvrir des
films inédits ou des oeuvres anciennes
pour seulement 3 euros l'entrée
on reste dans le septième art pour
enfants si votre rendez vous dans les
salles saint-quentinoise avec patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
je vous propose un événement
exceptionnel donc ce samedi à 14 heures
ça commence par une projection avec un
programme de courts métrages liberté 13
films poème c'est la collection en
sortant de l'école donc qui a déjà
produit des des programmes sur des
poésies
donc voilà c'est des films poèmes et là
c'est sur la poésie de paul eluard donc
13 13 courts métrages pour treize jeunes
réalisateurs issus des écoles
d'animation
voilà notre humaine vraiment en avant la
poésie du delwart et joue avec avec
plein de techniques d'animation
différentes et plein de ton aussi de
voilà deux récits très différent très
variés et c'est l'occasion d'accueillir
une peau est donc la peau est pascal
petit qui vient nous proposer un atelier
d'écriture de poésie etc offerts par les
itinéraires poétique
donc c'est accessible à partir de 6 7
ans et c'est aussi pour les adultes
donc n'hésitez pas et en plus vous aurez
un goûter donc ce samedi à 14 heures à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]
travaillez votre équilibre le cirque
dans les étoiles à aubergenville vous
invite à un stage de monocycle dirigé
par l'uci carbone triple championne de
france de monocycle freestyle l'art du
pédalier vous délivrera tous ses secrets
ce week-end météo france prévoit du
soleil le temps ne sera donc pas une
excuse pour hâter la 38e édition du
cross de la sablière 6 km ou 11 km et
même des courses enfants dans les forêts
de meudon et versailles ce dimanche 17
février un peu de magie et de monstres à
l'intérieur du périphérique direction le
1er arrondissement de paris un parcours
interactif pour chasser les monstres et
découvrir la culture japonaise
l'exposition monstre mon gars et murat
camille ouvre ses portes au musée en
herbe
reportage de maylis kerhoas de nos
confrères via grand paris c'est l'heure
de la chasse aux monstres au musée en
herbe de paris
découvrez en immersion tout l'univers du
manga cela commence par la découverte de
takashi murakami un peintre et cinéaste
japonais dont les oeuvres sont souvent
qualité de kauai qui signifie adorable
en japonais les enfants
en arrivant dans l'exposition vont
devenir des petits chasseurs de monstres
ils vont retrouver les monstres dans
l'exposition ils ont un petit bandeau
ils ont kippa rocky héros de manga de
mizuki qui lui-même est à chasseur de
monstres et ils partent avec un jeu de
piste et tout au long de l'exposition
ils vont à la fois découvrir grâce à
leur chasse au monde l'offre de murakami
les personnages de mangas et les
monstres traditionnel japonais
dans une 2e salon rampe est innocent ce
petit garçon à moitié robot qui met pour
la première fois les pieds en france il
est le super héros d'un court métrage
réalisé par murakami
puis on salue monsieur dob l'alter ego
de l'artiste un personnage inspiré par
les yôkai ces petits esprits malins
présent dans les légendes nippone ces
derniers seront souvent représentée par
des masques traditionnels on aille à
coups mais qui essuyé au sens mieux si
on raconte un mensonge si on vole
quelque chose il ya un oeil qui se
détache et la comète qui va nous suivre
partout ils ont classe tu as chaud car
c'est le cap à l'intro au dessus de la
tête avec de l'eau dedans ayant entraîné
les gens vers le marais mais on peut
tout à fait les combattre d'abord comme
les japonais sont très polis suffit de
saluer la manière chaplin s'asseoir là
il fait pareil toute l'eau qui lui donne
son pouvoir de son crâne une tombe on
peut lui offrir des concombres ce sont
ces mêmes monstres qui incarne également
les catastrophes comme dans les mangas
du célèbre hayao miyazaki il incarne
aussi le drame des tsunami qui a frappé
cette région comme sur ses tableaux de
la fable ii - camille vous avez jusqu'au
22 septembre pour découvrir cette
exposition
et c'est la fin de votre site choisi
remercie nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous la semaine prochaine
bonne saint valentin aux couples et aux
célibataires
m
[Musique]